Speaker 1: One more clip I want to look at
with you today.
Without making fun of anyone.
One of the things we've been talking about
this week and last in the context of the midterm
elections, when doing interviews like our
correspondent Luke Beasley did at a Trump
rally over the weekend, we have talked about
we're not joking here.
This is serious.
We've talked about how difficult it can be
to distinguish what is a cult member who has
been brainwashed, what is an ignorant person
and what is a mentally ill person?
When someone says, I think JFK Jr is alive
and is the president right now.
Is that something that you believe because
you're part of a cult?
Is that something you believe because you
just don't realize the truth about JFK jr
and when he was killed and how or is that
something you say because you're mentally
ill?
Or is it all three in some combination?
The.
Epitome of this Venn diagram is a tour called
Reawaken America.
Eric Trump, one of Donald Trump's children,
has been a regular attendee at these events.
This is a little clip from right before Tuesday's
election where they are striking the ground
with imaginary arrows to call upon God to
win the midterm elections for them.
Speaker 2: How many believe we're going to
have a victory on Tuesday?
Yeah.
So come on, let's give a victory shot.
Let's strike the ground and let's give a victory
shout.
On the count of three.
You're ready?
Yeah.
So here we go.
Get your arrows out.
Just go.
Speaker 1: Strike and strike and strike.
Speaker 3: Strike!
Speaker 2: Strike!
Come on.
You've got a strike.
Come on, strike.
Come on, strike the round.
Speaker 1: They've got the band and everything,
huh?
Speaker 2: Strike.
Come on.
Strike.
Speaker 1: This is.
This is.
I'm cringing.
I'm really cringing.
Unidentified: Come on.
Terrific.
Great, great.
Speaker 1: Okay.
Where is this?
On our Venn diagram.
Where is this on the Venn diagram of cult
brainwashing, simple ignorance and mental
illness?
I think it's a very difficult question and
I think it's an interesting question.
It's not about making fun of these people.
Now you know why it didn't work, right?
You know why Oz lost amphetamine.
One eye was striking with imaginary arrows
against Oz and it just canceled it out.
I did it so correctly and accurately.
I'm kidding.
But that's why this is all so insane.
I don't know the answer.
I genuinely don't know the answer.
I don't know whether we say this is a form
of mental illness and delusion, whether these
are just folks who have been brainwashed,
or whether they ignorantly believe that striking
the ground with fake arrows affects election
results.
I do not know, but Michael Flynn and Eric
Trump regularly participate in these events
and the interplay, the blending between.
Sort of elected officials, although Eric Trump
isn't an elected official, but political individuals
and these types of extreme religious events.
There is no fine line between them anymore.
They are together.
The American right wing political establishment
and the extreme.
I think these are evangelical folks.
Evangelical right wing establishment have
blended into one and that's where we are.
It's really scary stuff.
Let me know what you make of it.
I used to say, find me on Twitter.
Twitter is increasingly unusable because of
what's going on.
So make sure you're subscribed on YouTube.
Make sure you're following on Twitch.
Make sure you've like this on Facebook.
I want to hear from you.
Where is this on that?
Spectrum or circle or triangle of ignorance,
cult brainwashing and mental illness.
Let me know what you think.
The David Pakman Show is a viewer and listener
supported program.
We depend on your support and it is with your
support that I believe we are going to grow
the progressive media ecosystem at such a
critical time for American politics.
You can sign up at Joint PAC MSN.com.
You can
use the coupon code 24 starts now.
Yes, indeed.
24 starts now.